prosthetic arms for much of the 20th and
21st century looked like this while
prosthetic legs were running in the
olympics arms were being left behind
prosthetics uh it's a quite a
challenging product to develop it's not
going to replace or or surpass a human
hand it's a tool ultimately and it's
there to assist you and we have to make
it extremely functional but easy to use
but since the early 2000s private
companies governments and research labs
are developing prosthesis that are more
functional and a lot more advanced than
previous designs wire talk with easton
la chapelle founder and ceo of unlimited
tomorrow to understand how he designed
tested and adopted his prosthetic arm
so what are the options available for
those looking for prosthetic arms the
landscape of prosthetic offerings today
is quite a spectrum there's very simple
passive devices they look like a hand
but they don't have any type of movement
or function beyond just aesthetics or
cosmetics the next here is the body
powered so this is the classic kind of
hook and claw system usually you shrug
your shoulder kind of move your body to
be able to close an open claw and then
the next class is quite a wide one you
go into the myoelectric more robotic
class and then beyond that you get into
the research level where these are these
brain control devices that universities
are developing so the big question was
how can you design an arm that's
functional while also being affordable
easton started with this design this is
really what started it all this is the
very first robotic hand i made when i
was 14 and as you can see there's a lot
of simple household items it's a lot of
legos and electrical tubing at this
point it's very very basic
but this essentially validated that we
could use motors and tendons to open and
close fingers next was this model i made
this back in 2012 and this was really
the infancy of the consumer 3d printing
world you know these were essentially
kind of hot glue machines that extruded
material and sometimes they work
sometimes they didn't you can see it's a
very similar concept where we have these
servo motors that essentially pull these
tendons these fishing lines for the
increased grip i i decided to put these
little finger pads and this was was far
more functional i could actually pick up
things accurately and do a little bit
more real-life tasks with it their next
prototype was a little more sci-fi it
used an eeg headset which measured brain
waves to control the prosthesis so the
next prototype is what i call robo arm
and this was a lot of the concepts kind
of rolled into one here i found a lot of
benefit working with pendant systems
compared to other mechanical designs a
lot of other devices on the market use
linkages and so then when we looked at
tendons and especially the individual
finger joints essentially we want to
eliminate the cognitive bandwidth that
someone uh experiences when using a
prosthesis and an experiment with how do
we merge mana machine can we tap into
the brain without a surgery do you know
can we use external headsets or is it
best to go into the nerves the muscles
kind of
the area to be able to control the
prosthesis their next design went back
to the basics getting rid of the headset
and focusing instead on a 3d printed
material with a tendon system design so
this is like i'm learning from years of
prototyping bundling it all into a
single design here the socket is the
hardest part of a prosthesis and if it
doesn't fit right no one's going to use
it and this was actually replica for a
small grow name momo we would send
webcams and 3d scanners and xbox kinects
down to her house in florida where her
mother would scan her residual limb and
then we would generate a socket which is
how the device attaches to the person
and then there's a small band that would
read your muscles and then from there
she's able to open and close the hand
change the grips we still utilize today
of how can we create these natural
feedback loops to the brain we want to
supplement the brain we don't want to
take control or to create a secondary
brain
we want to we want to tap into exactly
how a human arm typically works
this is true limb this is our first
product we launched in june of 2020 and
when you look at this this is
essentially a robotic hand so each of
these fingers have individual finger
motion you can see these small tendons
in here we have about 14 joints that act
independent
so how does it work how can people with
missing limbs use their muscles to move
the device
it's one thing to read data from the
human body which we do through sensors
but then how do we input data back into
the body and into the brain how do we
provide feedback of are you touching
something that's hot or cold are you
picking up something with delicate touch
or are you actually really grasping it
it starts here with their feedback
system
we wrap the entire limb with with a
large array of these sensors and we look
for very small minute changes we try and
go as simple as possible right now we
use a vibration motor similar to what's
in cell phones the use of 3d printed
materials helps keeps costs down but in
the beginning the 3d printed landscape
looked a lot differently than today 3d
printing has come a long way since i
started uh back when some of the most
simple 3d printers made out of laser-cut
wood and
very simple plastic it looks incredible
but what we're finding is that it's very
brittle and so we kept having the pinky
break it's what you're going to bang
everything against on a counter and we
kind of reach the point where like this
is just not going to work for a
prosthetic device it's just not durable
enough and then so we started looking
into what's happening in the landscape
of 3d printing and it's actually where
we first started talking with hp they
created this incredible machine
that prints in full color but also in a
very strong nylon material innovations
in 3d printing meant stronger materials
which hopefully translates to more
resilient devices
so what's next for unlimited tomorrow
we're constantly learning constantly
doing research data collection that
helps influence the future the product
and so that's something that's really
high on our list is just to continue to
expand and just you know just make this
more and more accessible and we're
looking at forms of exoskeletons and
other types of technology uh to use
robotics and a lot of our foundational
technology to
you know help help give people uh you
know empowerment and accessibility and
mobility across the world